in 2016 bottled water outsold soda for
the first time in U.S history it's one
thing if you don't have access to clean
drinking water but this only applies to
0.6 of Americans most of whom it live in
rural areas but then why do people still
buy bottled water
well the answer is brilliant marketing
you see the soda industry isn't decrying
over the fact that people are moving
away from soda because they're the ones
who engineered this transition in the
first place take a look at this lineup
of bottled water at first glance it
looks like a good assortment of
different bottled water but many of
these brands are owned and or
distributed by none other than Coca-Cola
and Pepsi Coca-Cola is involved with the
Dasani seal and smart water while Pepsi
is involved with Aquafina Schweppes Life
water soapy sparkling o and Evian